welcome to the show it is sadly my
birthday I hate my birthday it's
February 2nd everybody knows I
increasingly hate my birthday I came in
and there was an amazing setup here from
pat including balloons a vegan dessert
of some kind it's a vegan Keurig coffee
cake wrapped in a silver lining
uuhhh so you it one of the ingredients
is Keurig coffee right yeah and it's a
coffee cake which is incredible and it
has a happy birthday message on it
there's balloons all over my desk and
there's a huge wrapped what feels like a
poster but I don't know what it is so
this is incredible Pat thank you I
wasn't expecting anything what should i
first try the cake oh absolutely yeah
alright this is a vegan Keurig coffee
cake I don't know how good it's gonna be
boom we'll see hmm
yeah berry coffee like okay very strong
coffee flavor which I like now you don't
like cured coffees no I don't know
you're gonna like the cake it's clever
but in a cake you can't really tell
whether it's carried coffee or not very
very good it's uh what is that
hazelnut no I'm kidding it's like a
regular coffee that's very good thank
you is this is this raw by the way is
this like a no no baked cake no no it
baked it if you didn't go with like egg
replacer and oil and you know regular
because you know house now the move is
you don't there's these no bake cakes
but very very good I like that okay good
should I open up this thing yes okay so
this is like a huge thing for right
we're watching it's wrapped with a bow
it is flat though it doesn't just keep
going in the back it is flat and we're
gonna open it up and see what this is
it's very tough to open it it could be
very very odd oh boy it's the Andy
Warhol poster isn't it this is very cool
artwork by a quarry top tip yes were you
in touch with quarry about oh yes
because I had to have him send me a
bigger file the one we usually show was
a big enough this is artwork so I'll
tell you something Cory was actually a
little bummed right in the calendar his
this was his image an Andy Warhol David
Pakman image and it was modified in
order to fit better with the proportion
of the calendar and Cory wasn't thrilled
but he was okay with it because it was
all in the interests of the calendar and
I understand that because artists can be
very particularly sort of thing it's
their artwork and they don't want anyone
else touching it so now this will hang
here
well why not I think I don't know if you
wanna have it in studio or at home but
that's what I could I mean I think the
it's a nice piece up here because when
people come in they'll say wow that's
interesting what is that this is very
very cool thank you I really love it
yeah and we will see if it's it's
already happy oh it says 34th / I was
hoping we wouldn't reference the number
are you referencing the number it does
say happy 34th okay on the back very
very nice now enquiries I wanted to wish
you a Happy Birthday I know the fans do
as well yeah but we have a couple other
people who also wanted to reach out
really yes
what do we have so first making his
first-ever appearance on the David
Pakman show
oh is this the Eggman David Pakman show
producer Noah Ferguson no way David Noah
here
happy birthday did you know that you
share a February 2nd birthday with some
pretty cool people like 6th century
Byzantine Emperor just in the first the
bass player from Stone Temple Pilots
Japanese sumo wrestler Tochigi yama
orion and obscure latvian hockey player
our tours clear day so you are in pretty
good company I hope you have a great
birthday weekend wishing you a happy
birthday from here in Virginia
let's take care yeah Noah Ferguson's
first ever appearance and I I mean Noah
is not in front of camera in front of
camera guy you know yeah that's stunning
I pull them along to do this yeah that
was fun and educational that's huge I
love that we also have one more okay and
this face is gonna be a little bit more
familiar to the audience is it let's say
David happy birthday Wow
it's your birthday Wow I would like to
wish you a super happy birthday and a
another year of growth and success
and to do Pat and Noah and all the fans
produce I would like to wish all of them
a happy David's birthday this is perhaps
the most important the most important
national holiday here in America and
Argentina and I just wanted to be a part
of it and say that so cheers buddy
Wow and that for people who are
wondering first of all why Luis sounds
like he's on the International Space
Station he's wearing his gaming headset
mic because it's now streaming himself
gaming he's on Steam it right yeah he's
on Steam it he's on Twitch he's all over
the place and that is I think an
unfortunate microphone choice but it
didn't impact in any way the beauty of
the birthday message and that that's
incredible
release the audience will be thrilled to
see that people do like the idea of Luis
Wow well this is this is incredible and
I am going to before I drown my sorrows
with the reality the realization that
I'm almost halfway to 40 from 30 by
number one pre-empting the emails from
people saying David it could be much
worse you could be turning X and it's
some higher number and it's like yeah I
get that but that's like when I tell a
22 year old listen you could be turning
34 and they say yeah but I'm not so I'm
focused on 22 not 34 and I'm gonna pop
all these balloons which is gonna be
quite quite an experience
Thank You Pat thanks to Noah Ferguson
thanks to Lewis please no gifts
whatsoever if you want to do something
just become a member or a patron and
here's to another year of the David
Pakman show great program coming up for
you today